second in a series of events that aim to
question broaden and reframe the way we
think about computing and design i am
david benjamin i teach here at the
school of architecture and i'm also the
co-director of the Living Architecture
lab and we're very happy to be
presenting tonight's event alongside the
department of computer science at
columbia in what we hope will become a
deeper partnership over time between the
schools of course collaboration between
architecture and computer science is
nothing new there's a long history of it
there's also a long history it seems to
me of architects adopting technologies
from computer science relatively late in
their development cycle so in other
words today's new thing in architecture
is often yesterday's innovation or tool
from computer science so one of the
things we want to explore tonight is
this if parametric the term parametric
is today's buzz word what might
tomorrow's buzzwords be can we
anticipate them can we absorb them early
in their development cycles can we also
challenge them and can we really
understand them beyond a superficial
level in order to make them more than
buzz words can we reach a point
ultimately we're architects and computer
scientists work together to co-evolved
the tools and the designs that apply
those tools where each one exerts forces
and friction on the other and both get
better in the process in order to
explore this we could not have a more
interesting and inspiring group of
speakers and the basic premise for
tonight is for each one each speaker to
demo a method or technology that might
be relevant to how we will be designing
architecture of 10 years from now before
we move on and get right to the speakers
I do want to thank
a couple of sponsors who support help to
make this event possible Blue Sky
Studios the Columbia Department of
Computer Science and Bentley Systems
Incorporated particularly Laura Meyer
academic director of North America and
now what I want to do is quickly
introduce my friend and colleague
Michael Reed the co moderator of the
event Michael teaches in Columbia
computer science he is senior research
associate at Blue Sky Studios and for
the past several years he's been an
important friend for the school being
involved with the development of several
classes here michael green thank you
very much David and good evening
everyone thank you very much for coming
tonight and thanks again to Bentley the
graphics group at columbia computer
science and especially to the graduate
school of architecture for providing the
platform for this series allowing us
some time to reflect and to look forward
on the relationship between computer
science and architecture for me the
promise this relationship is visible in
the sophistication of projects that
increasingly use the design geometry
itself as a program for automated
fabrication and construction but no
relationship is perfect and there are
plenty of missed opportunities on both
sides the example that I usually use is
John Fraser's groundbreaking work in the
late 60s and early 70s at the
architectural association work that
certainly would have formed the basis of
computer sciences ideas virtual reality
and human-computer interaction I'm
except for the fact that that work
really wasn't even recognized or
acknowledged in my field until very very
recently and in the other direction
there's parametric scripting which is a
design tool became widely available in
the mid 1980s in a very early release of
AutoCAD that was the first time that a
designer could write an interpretive
script that would generate form it took
about a decade for these ideas to
percolate to individuals researching in
an architectural venue
20 years until we see sort of widespread
experimentation that you all know today
if this is a form of technology transfer
I'd say that it is does not have much
merit to it the worst part is that's not
just inefficient but it seems to create
a situation where practitioners are
expending energy and searching for the
next big thing but only within very very
narrow interpretation of whatever ideas
were thrown over the wall so you have
situation where people are looking for
the next voronoi diagram a
mathematically beautiful pattern they
can just take it's easily scriptable
they can apply to a design situation but
without any contribution to the art of
practice without a deep commitment to
collaboration it's going to be very
difficult to be systematically
innovative so for that reason I hope it
tonight you here and hopefully see some
things that you've never seen before or
at least some ideas that are taken much
farther than you've ever thought
possible because on the cs side and that
means both in computer science research
and in product development this really
is the cutting edge so with that before
I introduce our first speaker I'll
mention that at the end of speakers will
have a period will have some question
and answer but in the meantime I'll
introduce our first speaker it's
Jonathan Cohen come on up and if you
need to plug in plug in jonathan is a
senior research scientist Nvidia where
he develops methods for applying in
videos massively parallel GPUs to palms
in scientific computing and real-time
physical simulation prior to joining
Nvidia he spent several years working in
Hollywood feature film visual effects
industry we developed software for such
films as spider-man 3 and the chronicles
of narnia this includes stints at sony
pictures imageworks and rhythm and hues
i received a technical academy award in
2007 for his work in fluid simulation
visual effects and with that are you
good to go
ok
yes
you
despite testing this just 15 minutes ago
we are having technical difficulties we
got it is that you or the other
switch someone else first um yeah we
could we could try that don't because
gonna go waste watch out one more secure
that we can bring in all right okay in
that case we're going to swap our order
temporarily hog would you mind starting
so if you want to give use how to be
great and we can reconfigure this and
get it going so I'll introduce HOD
Lipson Hut has been at to the school
before his work has some close
connections with some architectural
experimentation but I think you'll find
a lot of this very fresh so quick
introduction HOD Lipson is an associate
professor of mechanical and aerospace
engineering and also of computing and
information science at Cornell
University he directs the computational
synthesis group which focuses on novel
methods of automatic design fabrication
and adaptation of virtual and physical
machines he has led work in areas such
as evolutionary robotics multi-material
functional rapid prototyping you've
probably seen the YouTube videos of
these things machine self-replication
and programmable self-assembly lipson
received his PhD from israel institute
of technology and worked as a postdoc at
Brandeis University and also MIT his
research focuses primarily on
biologically inspired approaches as they
bring new ideas to engineering and new
engineering insights into biology HOD
Lipson Thank You pleasure to be here
tonight I'd like to talk to you a little
bit of a couple project that we're doing
by the one focus in particular one no
idea that we've been beginning to
explore and in robotics and I think it
might have implications to architecture
as well so I and that's the idea of
self-reflection so let me explain a
little bit where we're coming from so
there are a lot of I see you know we in
the
we mentioned this idea that architecture
takes can use ideas from from computer
science in Ithaca another area which is
combines computer science and
engineering is robotics and there are
far as I can see a lot of new ideas in
architecture involve various forms of
Robotics in particular reactive
responsive systems that actually measure
things and react to them in various ways
and this is just one picture of the web
of a reactive wall but there's many like
these and they correspond in a way to
something that in a kind of era in
robotics that happen maybe a decade ago
where there people started designing
reactive robots robots that didn't do
too much processing but they reacted to
their environments in various ways
someone like insect maybe and a lot of
interesting things happen and we've been
exploring that as well and so I want to
talk a little bit about the trend in
robotic and where I think this is going
in some of the new ideas that are coming
out so in the early days of robotics and
most robotics still today our program
it's just a programmer sitting down
designing the robot and then writing a
program that makes a robot do something
very specific and that works very well
in a closed environment where everything
is the right place at the right time and
the robot works and the factory and
everything's all well but this kind of
robotics fails when things change when
there is a need for adaptation which
something is not in the right place when
the ball falls off in those cases these
kinds of robots for them it's game over
they can't adapt or can react they can't
recover and so one of the biggest
challenges in robotics is to try to make
machines that can adapt to new and
unforeseen situations and we've been
doing a lot of work on that for for a
while and one of the earlier projects
was to try to make robots that evolved
literally use using the we need
selection like genetic algorithms
Genetic Programming and trend
learn over time and shape changes in
order for them to react in the
situations that these are I don't know
if I can play these but these robots are
evolved there we took a vat of robot
components in simulation and bred them
over a thousand generations that we got
these simple robots that can crawl
across the floor after doing that we
started taking the same ideas and
applying waking them work not in
simulation but in reality so we took a
existing robot this robot has 12
actuators 12 pneumatic actor isn't it
for execution then it is our first
lovely a litter and let it basically try
to press the random speech moment then
this one this one is a bit better I
didn't do very well trying to merge and
gradually on the feedback is getting
it's learning how to walk the way
basically what's happening is they're
walking off the controller of brains and
the skovox 78 is try different things
involve like a big move our walk faster
get to bleed more take them and we
combine it with other to failure to
produce new robots for were
congratulating the Queen City they get
better and better it's all ready to take
over there will be voting a walk and do
that without being program so teller
machine learning process but but here's
the key keep challenge so the first
project we did everything in simulation
and we downloaded it and we crossed our
fingers we hope that it worked but that
doesn't really scale because there is
what we call engineering the reality gap
you can have fantastic things in
simulation but when you make them in
reality doesn't necessarily work because
there's a gap between simulation and
reality and no matter how much time you
spend on your simulation is going to be
always this gap and it's going to be a
problem in the second problem a project
I briefly showed you here we did
everything in reality but the challenge
there is that the robot needed to learn
in reality and need to do lots of
physical trials and it took time and was
very expensive so that's a problem too
many physical trials when you have a
machine
or a system and you want to have it
learning reality just is too expensive
and too slow so the alternative and this
is the basic idea of self-reflection
which I want to put forward today is
this idea that you start off with a
simulation and you use it to generate
machines and let's think about
structures not just machines any any
kind of thing you want to actually
physically instantiate and then you try
it in reality you think the best thing
you have you tried in reality now
because the simulation is not going to
be good it to begin with probably the
thing you go to build is not going to
work very well but we're going to
collect data from the robot let's say
its experiences its actions and its
reaction so collect all this data and
now instead of just evolved in
structures we're going to evolve
simulators okay so in the first couple
examples i showed you revolve machines
now we're going to evolve also their
simulators with a figure of merit of
simulators how well it explains reality
in retrospect so now we're basically
co-evolving machines and they're
simulators and i want to argue that that
is self reflection but the machine
actually tries to generate new
simulators that explain its own
experiences that is a basically a
process of self-reflection it's not that
an engineer and architect hand-coded a
simulator to let the Machine figure out
what's going on but the machine does it
for itself so let me show you how that
works first for a simple robot and then
we'll try to see to project into the
future so this is a robot that we we
built it has four legs it has eight
motors two on each leg one of the hip
and one of the knee and it has two cells
tilt sensors that tell the robot house
tilted left and right forward and
backward okay very very sparse input now
this one what needs to learn how to walk
now the challenge is that this robot
does not know that it has four legs all
that it knows is that it has eight
mortars and it can feel the tilt angle
so imagine yourself sitting in a black
box with no windows and you have eight
knobs and you can turn the knobs and as
you
the knobs you can feel the Box leaning
left and right forward and backwards and
with that you have to learn how to make
the Box move forward so that's what this
robot feels like so to speak so the way
it works is that robot begins by doing a
random motion and it then formulate
hypotheses about our model simulators
these are these are hypotheses about
what it might look like and I'll show
you the movie in a second and you'll see
that all the hypotheses all the
simulators that it generates for itself
are wrong but they are in so far as the
robot knows they are all valid
hypothesis because they match its
experience you will know that they're
wrong because you happen to know what
the robot actually looks like it will
then and this is the key step it will
figure out what's the best action to do
to cause the most disagreement between
predictions of these models why because
the action that we will do the data it
will collect will then refute a rule out
some of the models and leave others
intact so we'll keep then we'll do a
physical experiment rule some of them
out and keep on going a circle until it
cannot disambiguate them anymore at
which one it has a good simulation of
itself and then it can make this the
model in simulation move forward and
because the model is pretty much correct
what makes the model move forward will
make the robot move forward as well so
here's an example of this thing working
and if I had more time I'd show you all
the failures as well but I'll skip
straight to the thing that works and
this is this is the robot doing its
first random action and now here are all
the policies that it's generating you
can see they're all wrong but it's kind
of figure out that they all make the
center of green block tilt in the same
way this is already ate that of 16
trials is beginning to figure out that
it's got four legs doesn't quite know
how they're hooked up and where and this
is ready the sixteenth trial out of 16
and it basically created a model of
itself ok now it's not a great model
it's not very accurate it's pretty
simple but nonetheless making that model
move forward will also make the robot
for we were hoping to for the robot to
generate some evil spider ewok but
instead cell then using that okay and
just to test it we remove the Lego watch
what happened so nothing happening try
this again the dynamics changed and then
it kind of internally begins to adapt it
small and basically lost the leg
internally if you look here it didn't
quite lose the leg it just made it very
short and then because it still has to
explain where all the eight motors are
and then it figured out a way to move
forward without legged again it's not a
great way moving forward but the basic
point here is that there was no sensor
that says
it's all about adaptation and if you
look at how this thing behaves red are
the random models what a random control
that does black is what the self model
predicts and blue is where the robot
reaches in physical reality which
suggests that the self models are this
is a robot from academia so the self
models are inflated but nonetheless it
allows the robot to move forward they're
interesting ways which is interesting
because it means that the self model
doesn't have to be accurate in order to
make the allow the machine before it has
to be good enough to allow it to make
the right decisions and you can do that
with working now is having a robot model
another robot like theory of mine and so
forth of things like that so you're
probably by now asking yourself okay
this is cool but what I have to do with
architecture this is all robotics and I
want to take a step backwards and take
it for more in the cake if we're talking
about machines that can model themselves
what can we do with that and you know a
lot of I see in robot in architecture
there's a lot of talk now about models
of buildings and building green
buildings that can turn off and on
sensors to maintain an environment and
so forth is a lot of modeling and
simulation that has to go on but we're
still usually talking about simulation
that some expert comes along you pay him
a lot of money and they create a model
of your building and that model is
probably going to be wrong a year later
right because everything changes so how
about thinking about buildings and
things that can actually adapt and
create a model of themselves and we did
one simple experiment that's somewhat
close with with with a structure not a
building this is a bridge I walk over
when out when I cross when I walk to
Cornell every morning until recently it
was more like this and when you cross
the bridge here you have a long time to
think what would happen if one of the
bars would fail
and so we said okay let's take the same
ID and apply to a bridge so this time we
have a bridge you can barely see it here
at the top with one element that's ten
percent weaker than it needs to be now
but this is a self modeling bridge so
what it does it has small vibrators
various places and these vibrators
vibrated the bridge and tiny amounts and
then the bridge can sense the vibrations
and from that it can create hypotheses
about what it is how we're pieces
connecting and how they're connected and
it forms multiple hypotheses and then it
creates new vibrations to disambiguate
to create to make these models disagree
in their prediction just the same way we
had with the robot and we've shown in
simulation that this process the bridge
can identify the broken of the weak link
a lot faster and more accurately than
traditional civil engineering methods so
this is just an example I will take this
idea and apply it to a to a structure so
we've talked about self reflective
robotics self-reflecting structures so
here's the the main point I'm going to
leave you with thinking about the future
you know can we make self-reflective
architecture that basically we have
objects or buildings that act and sense
and create using that data they create a
model of themselves they created self
simulation or self image that could be
of themselves of their environment and
of their users it's all together using
these models they can adapt to change
faster and we do that with fewer
physical trials just like the robot
didn't have to do all these physical
trials because it had the self model and
finally how can we take this from these
simple structures and simple machines to
complex things like cities I'll leave
you with this thought thank
alright let's see how this goes thanks
hard and we're good so once again I'll
give the short version Jonathan Cohen
senior research scientist an nvidia or
you gulps methods for applying in videos
hugely parallel GPUs to problems in
scientific computing and real-time
physical simulation and and with that
Johnathan sorry for that hiccup I think
the moral of the story is to never trust
technology so I'm going to talk about
time okay I'm gonna talk about
throughput computing and computational
graphics so these are two sort of
separate concepts but I hope you'll come
to understand why I think they're
actually really interesting and relevant
for people thinking about where
computers are headed in particular
design professionals who are used to
thinking of computers as a tool so the
way I want to approach this this idea of
throughput computing is to start out by
asking the question how do you measure
speed and I'm talking about the speed of
a computer so the simplest way you sort
of the intuitive way that you think
about speed as you say I have a task I
want to you know launch a render job in
light weight or whatever it is and I
look at the clock when I start I wait an
hour and a half hurt to finish I look at
the clock when I'm done and I say okay
that task took an hour and a half and
then a year goes by i buy a faster
computer i round it again and it takes
45 minutes so okay it's twice as fast
very simple intuitive sort of way of
thinking about speed but there's another
way of thinking about speed which is
maybe a little more subtle which is the
idea of instead of looking at a single
task and calculating how long that takes
is to think of throughput which is how
much can I do
second so thinking about sort of the
bulk rate at which I can do things and
so that the technical term for these the
first the first measurement is is called
latency and the second is known as
throughput these are sort of two
competing ways of thinking about how do
you measure the speed of a computing
device and they lead to very different
places and so the point I want to talk
what I want to talk about today is
throughput and so if you start thinking
about through but where does this lead
you so if your measurement is how much
can I do it once or I'm sorry is how
much can I do in a given amount of time
the sort of natural way that you would
think about doing improving this number
right is to do a lot a lot of things at
the same time and so there's this
inherent relationship between high
throughput and parallelism and by
parallelism I mean solving many problems
simultaneously and so if you design a
processor or a computer for
high-throughput the way that you
typically think about this is you'd also
design it to have very high amount of
parallelism so here's kind of a simple
conceptual model so let's say I have a
glass with water and I want to drink it
as fast as possible so if all i care
about is latency the way that you might
think about improving your latency at
drinking this glass of water is you
would buy a really gigantic straw right
and you would you would suck on the
straw as fast as you possibly can to
slurp up all the water all at once and
if you were thinking about this in terms
of throughput it would take sort of the
alternate approach which is I'd go to
the store i buy a pack of 100 straws I'd
stick them all in the cup and I suck
through all them at once and this kind
of illustrates that the two competing
ways that you would think about
designing a processor in fact so a
latency processor it tends to be very
fast very efficient very well designed
very expensive very sophisticated and
very good at doing one thing really fast
and the throughput based architecture
you have lots of little simple chords so
these sort of simple straws and the key
thing is to build something that's
scalable so I can jam more straws into
this top right and it'll keep getting
faster and faster and they don't
interfere with each other
carry the analogy too far i guess but
you sort of get the idea so I work in
Vidya that there's actually lots of
companies that are building processors
like this so I don't want to be like a
marketing shell it is great obviously
but but this is in the air and there's
lots of companies that are that are
thinking about computing in this way and
so our latest generation processor which
is called Fermi is a great example of a
throughput based processor and it's
designed for throughput so you might
think of you go to the store and you buy
a dual core or quad core CPU it has two
or four core as well well our ship has
512 cores and each of those pores can
actually do 48 things at the same time
so in total we can do 24,000 things at
once at the same time on one chip and
these aren't expensive chips you know
this is a this is a consumer commodity
device but the consequence of building
an architecture that's designed for very
high throughput is that it's really
really good at doing problems at solving
problems where throughput is the
appropriate way to optimize so math
problems are a great example you have a
very large math problem to solve in
almost every case you can chop it up
into lots of smaller subproblems solve
them all in parallel and Unferth for
example we can achieve over a trillion
flops teraflops one teraflops oh that's
a trillion floating-point operations per
second in single precision and in double
precision which is more accurate math
about half of a teraflop so you might
say well what is a teraflop that means
nothing to me so I want to put this in
perspective this is a chart from top 500
which is a website that tracks the 500
fastest supercomputers around the world
and so they have some methodology where
you can there's this benchmark you run
it on your computer and you can measure
how fast it is and submitted and may
certify results and so they've been
doing this for a long time and so this
is tracking the red the red dots here
going back to 93 is the single fastest
supercomputer in the world and this is
the logarithmic scale so so each one of
these is a factor of 10 you know it's
pretty remarkable just the steady march
in terms of speed this exponential
growth and the pink dots here are the
five hundredth fastest supercomputer in
the world so again you know marching
pretty pretty steadily and so for any
given year in between these two sort of
the range of the top 500 supercomputers
around the world so one Fermi chip which
you can now buy the consumer version for
about five hundred dollars and the
professional version next month or a few
thousand would be here so if you look to
about two thousand three in 2003 this
would have been the 500th fastest
supercomputer in the world so two points
first of all 2003 wasn't that long ago
so that's kind of that's that's kind of
rapid progress in my opinion point
number two if you actually look at the
processors that make up all these
supercomputers what kind of processors
are they made from with very few
exceptions they're made from processors
that are designed for low latency not
high throughput and its really only very
recently at the very top be sort of more
recent at the top end supercomputers
they're starting to use these throughput
oriented processors and so one reason
that we can have one throughput oriental
processor that you know consumer level
inexpensive and it can do so well is
because it's actually designed to be
good at this kind of thing you know in
the past we took these processors that
were good at low latency and then use
them to solve these these throughput
related problems and suddenly when you
it'sit's it really is a sea change in
computer science that's happening right
now is this recognition that throughput
is really the way that you want to think
about the speed when you're solving very
large math problems so the interesting
thing so you can go to the store and buy
spend 500 otters on this literally
little mini supercomputer and the
interesting question is what can you do
with it how does this affect you the
users of these tools so this is a just
kind of show plotting along this axis is
the amount of processing power so how
many operations per second process which
could do and kind of representation of
what kind of images you could create so
if you take all these
all these the power of these processors
and use it for graphics you can make
really impressive images so in the late
90s we had these um these processors
that bike today senators were quite slow
and you could do these not very well
tessellated polygonal models right about
two thousand three processors got fast
enough that you could actually implement
called shaders programmable shading so
you could actually write a little
program that specified the color of
every point and do much more interesting
effects and we're just at the point
today where you can actually do full
interactive global illumination in a
reflection much more realistic and
dynamic lighting models and you can
actually do them interactively on a
single processor so I'm going to show
you some demos of this so these are
actual products
please ok
so we're supposed to talk about the
future so i'm going to show you stuff
that it just today and you can
extrapolate after the future so this is
so we just released a ray tracing
library called optics and this is a demo
that we released you can actually
download from our website called design
garage which is just kind of showing off
as a proof of concept what you can do
when you have this kind of power so
design garage lets you take a car model
and put it in an environment and play
with material parameters and
interactively it generates these images
and so you can see now we can move the
camera and its interactive so as you
move around the quality goes down and
then you hold still for a few seconds
and it converges to a more accurate
solution so here's changing the the
skylight and so these are the kinds of
renders that people expect to take you
know a few hours right if people have
played around with these high-end
rendering packages the idea that this
could be interactive i think is kind of
mind-blowing to someone who's used to
running a full global illumination
solution on a complicated geometric
model so these are you know millions of
polygons this is showing we can actually
adjust the depth of field so stimulating
different focal lengths and again it
starts out kind of you know low quality
but it converges in a couple seconds to
something that that's it's actually
quite good so here we pulled in the
focus and now back to the mid ground so
now this is showing actually editing
material so again we can interactively
change the color we can change the
specular color versus the diffuse color
shading parameters and all the bounce
light all the stuff is it's recomputed
there's no nothing is pre computed we're
not reusing anything it's it's
restarting the calculation from scratch
every time you move that slider and it's
all interactive
this so this is showing a different
application this is something called
ambient occlusion which is a lighting
technique for getting these kind of nice
soft area lights and shadows for diffuse
the few shapes this looks kind of like
architectural models I think and again
showing its interactive so as you move
it goes to this lower quality and as
soon as you let the cameras stop within
a few seconds you have a basically final
quality image again you know compare
this to what you would expect it where
these are maybe 20 minutes to an hour to
get an image and here it is literally
interactive
so this is showing a different technique
recent work by some of my colleagues
Nvidia called photon mapping which is a
different method for calculating these
kind of accurate global lighting models
at the point here is that there's only
two light sources so there's this light
and there's this light and all
everything you see is completely
calculated interactively again and so so
you have everything from classics you
see the color temperature shifts as we
as we move the lights around and we're
getting red reflection vs green
reflection as the caustic here changes
and it spills more or less green light
into the room and all these really
complicated effects of the relationships
between the light bouncing in this space
again totally computer to interactively
so that's kind of a simple synthetic
case so let me just show a slightly more
interesting case so Morgan McGwire who
did this work put it in a game engine so
this is kind of cool this is a game
level in a game engine that that he's
been developing using this lighting
model and the cool thing about it is
there's only I think there's these three
spotlights and that's it so there's no
synthetic sheet you know ambient term
everywhere or these kind of hacks that
people used to do in game engines
there's real lighting there's three real
lights and that's it and and all of the
effects of bounce light I think there's
a here right so shining the light on the
wall and the walls red so you get this
warm glow off of the wall again all
interactively and if you if you've ever
done lighting and like a CG environment
or if you have any familiarity with it
this is just a completely different way
of thinking about lighting the game
developers are not used to lighting the
way the real world works they're used to
hacking it and the idea is that as you
change when you have enough computing
power you actually do these things
accurately
why so I'm going to show one more thing
this is some recent work yeah so this is
work that I've done recently applying
the same parallel processor throughput
or any third processors to realistic
interactive fluid simulation so this is
actually being characters as captured
from a high-end gamercard basically a
gtx 285 295 now 285 and it's actually
calculating the fluid flow of air around
the car so it's a took this little
driving game and we added this this
model for for air flowing over the car
and added these these little smoke
trails behind it and so we're actually
simulating in a rather realistic way the
airflow behind the car and if you think
of this as a design tool you know the
idea that you can have these models and
instead of sending it off to some
computer aided design package where you
wait 12 hours to get a result back this
isn't accurate enough that you'd want to
you know use this to predict real air
flow but from from the perspective of
getting a sense of you know how how
objects interact with their environments
these are very
these are very computationally intensive
problems but as computers get faster and
faster you can actually do more and more
of this stuff interactively night and I
think to a level already today that that
really exceeds what people expect it so
this is showing we can have three cars
and they're all interactive the last
thing i want to show you this is
actually my favorite demo so we took
exactly the same system but instead of
driving smoke we used a simple lift
model to simulate how this would affect
leaves so we start with all these leaves
on the ground as you drive the car
around it kicks up these leaves very
subtle effect but it's so realistic the
way that as the car moves around it sort
of pushes the leaves and I think what's
really cool about this is it the car
feels a lot more real than if we had
none of this right if you're just
driving this car around you say okay
that's the real fun but because you feel
the way the car is pushing the air and
that's pushing the leaves and the leaves
sort of fall back down it feels like
this car has weight and the interaction
of the carbon the environment just
really sells the idea that this is a
real car in this physical space so from
the perspective of how will you be
designing in 10 years you know I don't
really know but I think the idea that
you will have the computational tools
that will let you in a much more
realistic way explore the relationship
between your design and light and and
wind and air and and all these physical
things that are very very
computationally intensive I think that's
really going to change the way that the
capabilities people have in terms of the
tools is really going to change the way
that you're able to explore designs
rapidly and so that's all I had so thank
you very much
MichellePhan great perfect right okay
I'm tripping thank you and for a third
speaker we have a Makai Smith Makai is
the product manager for generative
components which many of you know is the
associative parametric modeling
environment from family systems he was
previously director of digital
fabrication for Chrysler & Associates an
architectural composites fabricator
where he oversaw pattern-making
operations employing laser scanning and
large-scale cnc he practiced
architecture venturi Scott Brown
associates in Philadelphia and holds a
Master of Architecture from Arizona
State University he's taught courses in
digital fabrication at Southern
California instead of architecture in
the University of California Berkeley
and as lecture in various schools
including Russia Pennsylvania School of
Art Institute in Chicago he's active in
Lake see I'm siggraph and created last
year's design a computation gallery so
um any luck we'll be able to connect
relatively trouble free
alright
we good sorry
great Corey with macaque Thanks thank
you Michael thanks David for inviting me
so I'm going to give you kind of an
integration it's view on on parametric
modeling also I'll speak about some
practical aspects of parametric modeling
but first I just like to frame this a
little bit by noting that you know
periods of flux in art and architecture
often reveal instances of what I've
called transitional forms you know from
a change in sensibility that accompanies
a new technology whether it's structural
steel and plate glass paint in tubes
that let Impressionists go out into the
open air and paint which helped give
rise to a kind of painterly style from
that or you know handheld movie cameras
and finally the availability of film
stock after the war to be able to shoot
a bunch of stuff and it employs you know
for grounding technique so violating the
180 rule and jump cuts things like that
they seem almost right through hindsight
without really jaded eyes I mean how
many copies of meat skyscraper have you
seen but it's kind of a hallmark another
characteristic is that they also don't
tend to last that long in their pure
form so you have your Java man and
parametric urbanism so if parametric
Scism is a style that's marked by
experimental uses of emerging software
platforms then my arrival at bentley a
few years ago coincides roughly with its
end because i helped to oversee the
release of GC as a commercial product so
it becomes just a fact of contemporary
history so in hindsight now I know
that's when you moved on to being post
parametric but so even as the
avant-garde moves on to something beyond
parametric the diffusion of this change
reveals the fact that people are more
difficult than technology success of
this enterprise is going to be
predicated on architects and designers
taking computational design into
everyday practice and this doesn't
happen uniformly so it's kind of
captured by the Asimov wisdom which is
that the future is here already it's
just not evenly distributed so there's
an often told history of Technology
Transfer you know David made reference
to it in the introduction it's all
throughout architecture different ways
just this example of the kind of smooth
and curvy computational representations
that came to Architecture from
engineering planes and and boats and
mcneil rhinoceros is an example of that
and so is generative components here
this is the work that dr. H did early in
his career in working in shipyards so
it's funny too because just aside my
father was a boat builder so I guess it
should come as no surprise eventually
that I come to be in the Karen beating
of GC the transfer of geometric modeling
technology is not complete we're
witnessing a new round of mature solver
and information modeling techniques to
be adopted in architectural cad so the
influence of mcat or mechanical software
it will continue unabated over the
period during which parametric design
will be adopted in mainstream practice
but to focus only on the aspect of how
tools become more and more parametric
misses the point it's the practice
dimension that's the hang-up so that's
why I show this example from foster and
partners specialist modeling group using
dimension driven design which is a
bi-directional solver that's been in
microstation for something like 15 years
so it's not just the presence of mature
technology that's sufficient it's its
deployment
this is an invitation that came to me
from my alma mater ASU for the
celebration of their 50th anniversary
and I got a chuckle because do you see
the difference neither do I just the
presence of computing isn't enough to
transform the studio in the past the
architectural design profession has
offered up some resistance to the
adoption of computation and I mean this
could be owing somewhat to it being a
humanity apart from engineering it all
could also just be the result of low
feeds you know in contrast to the
traditional studio the parametric office
will be characterized by the use of
computation as an intellectual or
creative act not just to produce
traditional forms in a more efficient
means so it will also be characterized
by a willingness to accept a role
reversal into traditional design
representations so the three 3d model
it's related views and sections are are
manipulated by a generative process in
this example is from Portman so that's
the model so the drawings themselves
even are just a derivative projection
from a model which is itself generated
so models like this take more time to
set up but as you know they produce kind
of change for free a kind of endless
infinite change which is itself a kind
of problem I think so what about
drawings
though annotation in the model will
replace drawing sets as we know them now
nothing will replace the inescapable
precision of locating space on a plane
because above all else sectioning is a
conceptual act so its primary in it and
it will stay with us over any given
future look at at architectural design
post parametric assumes that adoption is
complete that software companies have
solved all the difficult problems and it
implies successful deployment of
parametric technology within
architecture practice at large but
architecture is quite a different
circumstance than aerospace contracting
and engineering so for example arrow
Airbus which helped to develop this
change management or requirements
management software when it finds itself
within CAD it manifests in a different
different way so now you see a graph
that's being used to attract the
relationship among reference files which
are themselves an adaptation of CAD data
storage to architectural work packaging
right so the way that we organize our
drawings and organize our thoughts
Bentley strength in this respect comes
from what seems like an overwhelming
amount of really mundane software
something like 180 applications for
engineering large infrastructure
projects but projects like these often
have large owner operators who hire
called epc's engineer procure and
construct they do a turnkey job often so
this kind of lump sum contract means
there's a the reward structure for the
EPC highly motivates the adoption of
data modeling and digitally integrated
work processes such as the clash
detection and markup workflow that you
see here in order to manage risk and
that's why parametric design tools are
more mature in the civil plant and
structure segments where information
modeling has been used for decades
rather than architecture which despite
our enthusiasm is a relative newcomer to
the field so my point here is that it's
not necessary to misuse software taken
from entertainment or from mechanical
design when such tools are being
developed in parallel alongside us
within the allied professions and they
just simply need to be well they need to
be adapted for architectural practice
sure to take advantage of this require
software systems that recognize the
loosely coupled distributed
heterogeneous and temporary nature of
infrastructure projects and building
projects the approach has to be based on
operational and managerial independence
graph geographic distribution and
increment incremental implementation and
this is to allow kind of emergent use
right the pieces have to be
reconfigurable in such a way that all of
the uses aren't worked out at the time
that they were designed and so this is
an example it's a bit needs a solution
the call dynamic plot but it's basically
allows a paper-based workflow the
interesting thing about this is that it
didn't really require any new frameworks
to be developed by bentley it's safe for
the hardware for the pen that can
recognize a kind of micro dot pattern
so all drawings in space are unique once
plotted you just grab the pen you start
drawing and it actually knows which
drawing you were drawing on in the
mark-up shows there and it's a kind of a
good recombination of the technology and
it took advantage of the existing data
and metadata that's already being used
in the managed document environment so
here's another example using generative
components about how we're making the
using the platform's pieces to work with
design data in a more distributed way
this is an example of passing parameters
between systems so what you have here is
a city model that has attribute data and
by capturing a modeling process that
process can be based upon the input data
as held on the on the elements this is
an approach that's different these kind
of point-to-point connections that you
often see between software packages
where one makes an add into another like
you might like generative components and
create an add-in for it that runs
simulation within the package and these
work really well for a single team
that's a tightly coupled group or an
individual who's working in multiple
roles but they don't scale well for the
kind of long-chain dependencies that
work across parametric zones so instead
of instead we can use an approach that
just looks at persisting the parametric
data in the design repository then
letting each software zone interpret and
consume the parametric data in its own
way so this is a feature in a kind of
beta version of GCM called element
sensor and I guess the takeaway about
that is it wraps both the geometry and
the non geometric data and exposes them
another little point to make about this
is like the square that you see there
being moved by the cursor is just a raw
element it's just like your typical dumb
geometry and the block is a parametric
component that's creating a volume based
on like using a logarithmic function
just
measuring the area of the square to
prove the point but you know there's
different conceptual acts here there's
tweaking which is a nonparametric thing
of just like manipulating something till
it looks right and then there are
parametric components that have to
respond and so there's a role for the
parametric and a nonparametric and we
have to design the system to punitive
cognitively to appreciate both so before
I conclude I just want to call out what
are probably the two counteracting
tendencies here in how we might design
these systems there's gravity and
centrifugal force gravity comes from the
efficiency and computability of creating
a total model and you know it has to be
computable you're trying to manage it
trying to get it all in one place versus
centrifugal force because as we know
architecture like any other creative
enterprise as a rotating body and it
wants to spin itself off there's all
these different representations of a
design and that they have unequal weight
they change through time and by observer
so the representations themselves are
relative and just so despite the
computability and efficiency of a sort
of totality of a data model the master
model concept it's just untenable so I'm
you know I vote fragmented for the win
and so will approach this it's very
difficult to kind of manage design that
way and to put it in a computable form
and so we'll have to use all of these
individual techniques like parameter
passing and more heroic things like like
search across repositories or change
management systems
so this leaves me in rather conveniently
with only just a couple of moments to
talk about the future this is
quintessentially pre parametric you know
it took catia to make the fish but this
is parametrics purely in the service of
willful for making the fish in gary's
own words is a kind of like an icon ten
thousand years it's a pre rational
thought but now that we've learned what
the tools can do for us and incorporated
them into our design thinking about you
say like continuously varying things
what happens when we've made every fish
in the sea this is mathematica you know
so this stuff becomes trivial so for one
thing i just make a couple of
observations and then quit so i think
Joel sapolsky kind of pegged it saying
that design has to move from the user
interface to the social interface we've
seen the rise of social informatics as a
discipline and software that supports
social networks attached to or embedded
in work processes and something like
Google Apps has a twinkle of this and
sort of sort of sharepoint or something
but this stuff is just really not in
architectural cad as we know it yet
pervasive search and access to big data
that complements the social dimension
together represents the full saturation
of applications by the network and this
has already happened in our daily lives
with mobile computing and and hopefully
will be followed by smart buildings so
it seems inevitable the time scale over
which this is going to happen i think is
easy to underestimate given the way that
architectural practice functions with
its adoption of techniques
so I you know my my my point really is
just to learn from infrastructure design
because you know this polygon that
selected that used to be a kind of hatch
pattern for a space is actually now just
a geometric carrier as a place to put
the description of the space on which
wheel base of parametric modeling
process the the period of Technology
Transfer following from M CAD is going
to more more mature things is going to
continue for a while I think but it's
really going to be the deployment of
this stuff on on construction projects
and the on design teams and I think
we're in a pretty good position now to
learn from kind of our or the other
professions within the allied arts but I
think for the pervasive social computing
aspect we're going to have to look
somewhere else thank
I think
great okay um fantastic thought right
our next speaker is a tank Greenspun a
ten is associate professor of computer
science here at Columbia University
where he directs the computer graphics
group which is part of the Columbia
vision and graphic center um he was
invited professor at University teairra
Marie Curie in 2009 in Paris research
scientists at the Quran Institute of
mathematical sciences at NYU from
2003-2004 he got his PhD from California
to technology in 2003 and Vidya fellow
in 2001 everhart distinguished lecture
in 2003 and as an NSF Career Award in
2007 and very pleased to eight hands BTW
today the interactive exploration of
design spaces thank you so much mike is
this thing working
is the mic working can people here okay
because I can't hear it so all right let
me just dive right in first I want to
talk to you about my field just to set
things up I work in computer graphics
and traditionally the first thing we're
interested in computer graphics is the
display of images of course naturally we
think of movies but also computer
graphics is used in preservation of
artwork and in visualizing architecture
now what all of these images have in
common is that they're stationary the
frozen in time and the particular area
of computer graphics that I work in is
the computation of motion so if i have a
scarf that's moving through the air we
can ask ourselves how does it move and
how can we compute that motion so what
what sort of questions we need to ask
ourselves we need to ask what sort of
forces are acting on the scarf and how
are those forces propelling it forward
in time so those are some some of the
considerations that we're thinking about
in my research lab here at columbia now
when we're trying to compute the motion
of a physical object one of the things
we might be interested in is having that
motion predict physic predict reality so
if we crush a can and we see this
formation of pattern these diamond
patterns we might be very interested in
those and we want to make sure that
indeed when we crush an actual can we
also get such a formation of diamond
pattern so we care about the simulation
being predictive another and of course
if you extrapolate from that that leads
to such applications like crash tests a
virtual crash testing for cars and so
forth another application of country of
competing motion is just that the
process itself of figuring out how to
compute the
can teach us for example if we program a
very simplistic model and we neglect the
certain force we neglect friction and or
we neglect computation of the vortices
under the wing of a flapping inside and
we're still able to get the flying
motion of the inside that teaches us
that that particular physical element is
not critical or is apparently not
critical to that particular motion and
so in particular in the study of a bird
flight and insect flight the act of
programming a computer in order to try
to mimic that motion has helped
physicists to learn which forces are
important and which are not important
here's a recent example of some work
we've done in this work here we have
some honey that's poured onto a moving
belt and as the belt speed slows down
you get different patterns that form
first you get this meandering then you
get this chaotic region then you get
this figure eight pattern and it is
continued slowing down you get more and
more patterns here you get a coiling
pattern now it's interesting is that in
the University of Toronto some
physicists ran the same experiments but
with actual honey on a moving valve and
they were able to get a lot of these
patterns and in fact many other patterns
so many that this was known as the first
fluid sewing machine so simply pouring
honey onto a moving belt you get all of
these sort of patterns that you expect
to see in a very fancy sewing machine
and you can imagine that this has a
bunch of applications one of which is
effortless decoration of cupcakes right
but more seriously if you're working on
electronics and you want to generate
different sort of patterns of applying
molten metal which is a viscous liquid
onto a substrate you can now look at
applications where you don't have to
vibrate or move the head just by the
speed at which you move the head you can
apply different patterns onto the
substrate this is also interesting if
you're interested in making flexible
electronics or stretchable electronics
because now by moving the the speed at
which you deposit the the conductor you
can get the nice zigzag that you need in
there in order that when you stretch
these materials the conductor does not
break and one more area of application
is baby diapers and surgical masks and
astroturf so what all of these have in
common is that thirty percent of the
textiles in the whole world are not the
woven textiles that were used to thirty
percent of them are made by this process
if they're a class called non woven
textiles and they're basically made by
taking some molten polymer inside a
spinning drum that has a few heads like
a shower head that sprays out this
molten stuff and then it gets tangled up
interwoven and then hardens and so
understanding the behavior of these
multi liquids can be very interesting in
terms of these manufacturing
applications I'm going to give you one
more example of the sort of work we've
done and then I'm going to move on to
the next topic similar to looking at
thin flexible fluids that are falling on
a belt you can think about looking at
Twizzlers or other thin fibers may be
human hair so all these sort of objects
that when you twist they get these sort
of interesting patterns our group has
worked on that and actually today just
this morning adobe announced the next
release of Photoshop and illustrator cs5
and one of the new features you can read
more about it on their website is a new
physically based paint brush that's you
based on this technology we developed
here at Columbia where now the new paint
brushes in Photoshop have these live
dynamic physical bristles that you can
paint with and get lots of interesting
effect
and the same technology that went into
Photoshop is also being used in a more
literal sense at what a digital for
simulation of hair so this is the
company that did Lord of the Rings and
avatar so that's the sort of work we do
in our group it's basically taking a
physical system understanding it
figuring out what parts of it can we
safely throw away and then computing the
rest of it as efficiently as possible so
how does that relate to today's topic
well I was asked to think about and
speak about design and what that has to
do with my field and in some sense I've
you design as a process of exploration
this is coming from someone who has not
been educated in design so it's a very
naive but it's my my approach to
thinking about it as a process of
exploration I have some set of
parameters it may be many parameters and
now I want to try to figure out within
the space of parameters what are
interesting acceptable possibilities
what are not acceptable what violates a
fire code what doesn't and I want to
explore this space now typically the
space doesn't have two parameters
typically it has way too many parameters
in fact it could have an infinite number
of parameters so we need to think of a
few strategies for addressing this now
just brainstorming this and that there's
kind of two strategies you might take
one is to go parallel if we could only
figure out how to evaluate many possible
designs all at the same time right so
how might you go about going parallel in
a design space exploration one way is
maybe to use parallel hardware right so
we heard a little bit about some
promising directions from that from
Jonathan a little earlier and I'd like
to show you one demonstration of some
very nice work done at Cornell with
exactly this idea of exploring many
possibilities in pair
also here the idea is that an artist in
a studio is trying to design some
animation maybe for a game and they want
to achieve a particular result so what
this what these blue paths that you're
seeing here are are many possible
trajectories of this catapult that the
computer has figured out all by slightly
turning the catapult in different
directions by changing the weight by
changing the force of gravity and so on
and so forth and the user is presented
let me go back to that per second
right so a whole bunch of these have
been set up and what the system offers
the user now is a sort of Google for
design space so what's going on here is
by drawing these red red boxes the user
is narrowing down to only those
trajectories that pass through the red
boxes and by drawing the sorry that's
green I should have said green throat
and when drawing their red boxes the
user is excluding those trajectories
that go through those red boxes so you
can look for trajectories of the stone
that pass through certain regions on
Miss other regions and here's a another
example where this sort of idea can help
you to find physical but very
implausible trajectories of a person
falling down stairs so here's a person
falling down stairs and most of the
trajectories you see here are taking the
person completely off the side of the
stairs but sometimes you have these
unlikely scenarios where you can have
these unlikely scenarios where the leg
gets caught and so if one of the
trajectories happens to find the one
where the leg gets cut the google search
essentially allows you to hone in and
that interesting trajectory so by having
the hardware just complete lots of
possible trajectories and then honing in
on the ones you're interested in that's
one possibility another thing that you
might do is you might go parallel but
not in hardware but in the software that
is go parallel in a human sense so not
computer software but people software
and there's been a bunch of interesting
experiments in doing this and one of my
favorites is the folded project so
protein folding is extremely hard the
idea is you have some protein and you
want to know what you have the formula
for them you want to know what shape
does it actually take and even super
computers cannot solve this problem so
the idea is maybe if we have many people
working on it we can solve this
problem so there is some work from the
University of Washington where you can
basically go online and you can download
this game it's a really fun game it's
called folded and let me see there
should be sound here well we're not
going to get the sound but I baby oh
there is a sound so as I go through
these levels i'm actually playing with
us and trying to fold the blue and i get
feedback this is just a very simple
tutorial level entertaining and so you
have you have tens of thousands of kids
all over the world that are folding
these proteins and the computer is
giving them feedback on how they're
doing so that's another way to go
parallel I need to get rid of this first
okay so that's natural strategy number
one is go parallel strategy number two
is to say well maybe we can make some
more intelligent decisions as we explore
this design space so lubricate the
design loop what I mean by that if you
think of a typical design loop is saying
you have some idea you try it out you
either build it you build a little
mock-up of it you evaluate it you you
get a crit and then you go through and
revise it and make new ideas if we can
speed this up somehow so of course we're
used to the idea that a computer can
replace some of the building we can do
previz we can do some renderings we can
see how things will look maybe that can
save us time but can we get this loop to
be really fast can we really get it to
the point where we eliminate the
distinction between all these stages and
it gets to be really fluid I think the
way I kind of think about it is
interaction builds intuition if I gave
you one of these little puzzles that you
have to pull apart and I said
at this for two hours just in your head
just looking at it then pick it up and
solve it or if I gave you five minutes
but you could play with it you have a
better chance if you played with it for
five minutes then if you stared at it
for two hours and then what made one
attempt at it so really interacting with
the system builds a lot of intuition so
this is a mock-up of a project that
Carnegie Mellon called clay tronox where
the idea is if you had a holographic
display if you had actual physical tiny
little robots that assembled together
and that you could edit then you could
really work through a very quick process
with many people interacting at the same
time I want to show you not physical
versions of that I think I'm i only have
like three minutes left is that right
more or less i'm going to skip this I'll
go back to that at five time okay so
here is some work by nobuyuki Mitanni
who is visiting our group from tokyo
university he's here for the next year
and nobuyuki is interested in getting
kind of blurring this design loop in the
sense when you're interested in finite
elements or physical construction so
what you're seeing here is that as this
shape is edited which is just a
constructed shape before any physics are
applied you're seeing at the same time
what this shape does when you have
gravity acting on it so you immediately
get a as you edit the actual material
you're seeing instant feedback and what
happens to the deformed shape under
gravity so this can give an engineer a
lot of intuition about what's going on
now I also want you to look at this and
say this is a really neat idea this is
the state of the art and this is a very
very simple mesh in two dimensions so
we're really far out from being able to
do this for a complex model at
interactive rates
but already this shows you the sort of
power of having the stuff be very
interactive from the get-go here's a
vibration analysis so this platform is
vibrating what the user is editing in
real time is the shape of this box or
the height of this box or placing
windows or holes in it and they're
immediately seeing interactively as they
edit this how the shape is vibrating
this can help build intuition presumably
in the long run for things like
understanding how different shapes
behave under earthquakes similar
examples for wind tunnels and vortex
field so this is a fluid simulation so
you're kind of getting the trace of all
the smoke going through this wind tunnel
as you put different obstacles in the
way again a very powerful idea to be
able to do this interactively still in
very much the primitive stages and I
think this is a really fun application
because I love tea so here you're seeing
a fluid simulation and what you're
seeing is editing of the shape of the
teapot and if you had some understanding
of how you'd like the convection to
circulate nicely in there then as you
design this product you would get
immediate feedback on how the shapes and
I think that again by playing with this
interactively you can get a real feel
for what's going on
very very simple
feedback on how loud things sound as you
change the height or shape of the world
the system could presumably also show
you the cost of the wall and building
time when other things so the idea is
strategy number two is if you can
interact with the design system in real
time you can get an intuitive feel for
what's going on so that's what I was
just thinking are two of the possible
strategies and some of the just give you
a sense of some of the state of the art
in those technologies and of course I've
been showing you work by a bunch of
different people I thank you very much
our last speaker tonight is my co mot
samora only works at servo but until
very recently he was vice president and
chief strategist at software AG which is
the largest independent provider of
business infrastructure software Miko is
a thought leader in the areas of cloud
computing interoperability and
service-oriented architecture SOA in
fact miko literally wrote the book SOA
adoption for dummies Miko is also last
year named one of the world's 30 most
influential virtualization bloggers
prior to his work with SOA Miko was
chief Java evangelist at Sun
Microsystems and he has raised countless
millions of dollars for software
startups Miko holds an MBA from San
Francisco State and a master's degree in
neuroscience from Yale thanks Miguel
great very much appreciated so I'm very
excited to be here and thanks very much
for the hosts and for all of your
valuable non-refundable time so thank
you very much feel a great onus I'm also
amazed to be following these speakers
quite an astonishing array of
intellectual power so I feel it is my
duty to create a absolutely beautiful
intact synthesis of everything that
you've seen and tie a bow around it
but unfortunately I believe that I'm
destined to fail in this effort we're
moving into this notion of post
parametric era and the thing that this
evokes is it evokes another post that
comes from the architectural realm which
is that of post-modernism so right
around the bend acetal we saw this
wonderful poem that was evoke by Makai
when he was talking about the centrifuge
I which is this construct of the
widening gyre right this sort of descent
into the center not being able to hold
and of course this is the tissue of
modernity being completely rent and of
course the center ultimately did not
hold and we experienced the breakdown of
the dominant meta-narrative which
eventually resulted in the destruction
of this whole cloth sense of meaning in
the world and subsequently reduced human
endeavor into the squabble for power in
the ruins of the dominant meta narrator
okay so much for beautiful synthesis
okay so that's pretty grim so what i
thought i would do you i thought i would
counterpoint anytime's very optimistic
one of the things that's clearly true is
you know when you come from a provider
of business infrastructure you begin to
realize the fundamental limits of scale
end up being the human factors
themselves right so the thing that is
very interesting I had lunch with an old
friend of mine and he is an architect
and he's actually struggling not with
post parametric but he's struggling with
parametric which is his firm is shifting
from AutoCAD into Revit and he feels
like he's old and over the hill and all
these young kids coming you know out of
Columbia no hafez great software and you
know it's almost like he feels like he's
clinging by his fingernails to this
immense ball of complexity because what
emerged
in this kind of paradigm of software
developments I you know I till recently
work for a billion and a half dollar
software company is that the software
companies evolved with the buyers not
the users so they really design their
software towards rfi's and rfps where
you have billions of check boxes of
features and at which point the user
ends up in this staggering ball of
complexity right because essentially
what's happened is is that in the sort
of domain of the kind of henrik ibsen
master builder paradigm essentially this
piece of software is attempting to
swallow the universe of complexity and
it's you know only one piece of software
so this is a huge challenge because
really you you don't want to experience
this sort of degeneration of descent
into horrifying complexity as you start
to manage these extremely densely
interconnected variables because in the
emergent field not only is the architect
functioning much like the and rand
character in The Fountainhead Howard
Roark the Magnificent bold individualist
in a sea of sort of rampant collectivism
right so you know this is one vision for
architecture obviously not the dominant
vision at this time but the concern is
essentially that the architect is not
operating the silo of architecture but
in fact is integrated into a holistic
system with people who actually
constructed manufacture designs and who
in fact are part of this entire
so-called commercial supply chain of
space creation right so in any case
brings me to a quick question which is
what is architecture look like 10 years
from now so you know I'll say it right
away I have no idea but what I'd like to
do is take a few buzzwords so I think
clearly it will be distributed and it
will be approachable by scale by massive
scale whether it is computational scale
or the scale of the problems that are
faced
so you know New York is pretty big city
but if you look at a place like San
Paulo Brazil 22 million Tokyo 35 million
population one of the exponential
factors of growth in scale is human
population so we'll be dealing with
really interesting issues around
architectural design scale but also this
construct of externality things like
pollution things like regulation so the
design environment becomes extremely
multi-dimensional a heterogeneous and
has thousands of different externalized
constraints interoperating against the
design right rampant collectivism indeed
so perhaps a scary environment
integrated so will be an integrated
architectural model I think integrated
is important in the sense that one
person's tools will be integrated with
other different peoples tools that have
different jobs and different job
descriptions it will be interactive in
real time potentially even kinetic and
intuitive right which is really critical
which is the design of these systems
must achieve a level of simplicity and
intuitiveness for each type of user now
we could also envision a design
environment which is smart and
exploratory so these are all really
wonderful aspirations but unfortunately
the scope of my talk is actually pointed
in a slightly different direction which
is I'm here to actually talk about the
cloud so I'll try to compress that into
the remaining minutes I have because the
question becomes you know does the cloud
hold out the promise of helping us
achieve some of these design goals for
the architect of the future so I believe
that what we have here is wonderful
example of Occam's razor which is I
talked about exponential functions
creating challenge like population but
one of the things that's driving our
world is the exponential ax t of
Technology and emergence now if you look
at cloud I'm going to tell you what
cloud is in a moment but it really is
infrastructure and if you think about it
as infrastructure
it's boring all right i mean pavement is
infrastructure also we don't think a lot
about pavement we don't spend a lot of
time thinking about it now is the
pavement changing exponentially maybe
not so another thing to consider is
other than the extreme boringness of
infrastructure is infrastructure its
best is invisible or close to invisible
and we only notice infrastructure when
it's not working well alright so the
compute infrastructure is undergoing
exponential change and that's one of the
principles of what at this Occam's razor
concept which is you know we have big
problems that are driven by exponential
growth of things like population and we
have exponential growth of Technology so
Occam's razor says let's just smash
these two together and see what happens
maybe something good all right so
perhaps not the best amount of reasoning
but it's decent idea because human
beings are really bad at understanding
exponential functions so that means it's
a fun area think about Moore's law of
course everybody knows every 18 months
bang doubling of transistors on a die
for the same cost there are other laws
Gilders law Metcalfe's law that cover
the doubling of bandwidth of network
value there's a ram doubling law there's
a storage doubling law these are all
doubling the thing that is fundamentally
not doubling is human beings ability to
work and play well with others so in my
job so I recently put my money where my
mouth is and recently joined a company
called servo which is a zero billion
dollar startup focused entirely on
constructing a mobile data cloud so
that's my fascination with the cloud but
in my work at software G I worked on
integration software to glue together
parts of banks and governments
big big institutions so this got me
involved in service oriented
architecture and that's where some of my
background comes from so infrastructure
changes are hard to understand so here's
a quote from the British parliamentary
committee that studied electric lighting
they essentially said electric lighting
is good enough for our transit
transatlantic friends but unworthy of
the attention of practical or scientific
men very very dismissive this whole
electric lightbulb thing it's a fad we
just have to sit tight what why why does
a person think this way here's why they
think this way it's very simple it's
very simple because there's already an
infrastructural mechanism for delivering
light it's the gas lighting system which
was ubiquitous so the concept that you
would change such a thing is almost
insurmountable but in fact change does
happen so I guess what I wanted to talk
about is scalability which is I think
people have been accustomed to the
principal scalability as being Moore's
law which is we are limited by the
availability of compute and in fact the
thing that's funny is is I mean you know
I'm a dad so you watch a kid if there is
some limit then that's all that gets
focused on so kid will look at that
limit and say as soon as this barrier is
lifted my life will be perfect and
computer people have thought that as
soon as you get as much compute as we
need life will be perfect that isn't the
main problem of scalability so cloud so
what is cloud it's this very large
paragraph this is the national institute
of standards and technologies definition
and probably the most ubiquitously
agreed-upon definition for cloud
computing essentially it suggests a
utility model paying per usage and it
allows
shared pool of compute resources to be
rapidly provisioned and D provisioned
with very little interaction so it
basically means like an electric grid
you pay for what you use if you use a
lot boom you have a lot if you use a
little boom you have a little it's not
that weird of an idea comes with these
characteristics models and deployments
so the five key characteristics are on
demand and self-service ubiquitous
network access which means you can get
to it on your cell phone or whatever
location independent resource pooling
that means no matter where you are you
can get to stuff rapid elasticity which
just means that it scales up and down
whenever you want and pay per use those
are the five key characteristics three
delivery models are
infrastructure-as-a-service so Amazon
compute cloud platform as a service
things like Microsoft Azure Google App
Engine and things like
software-as-a-service things like
salesforce com google nail gmail google
docs anything that's delivered as a
service this way so those are the
delivery models and then finally for
deployment models one is called private
cloud where you as one entity owned
every single piece of hardware there's
some debate as to whether that's quote
on quote a real cloud or not community
cloud were multiple organizations share
a single resource that's distributed
this way public cloud which is the most
common and ubiquitous cloud concept so
something like Google public cloud and
then hybrid which is any combination of
public and private clouds so those are
the four deployment models so the goal
is to go from the very small all the way
out to the very big right so scalability
so the thing that I wanted to get across
to you is that scalability is not
compute constraint for long it may be
compute constrained now but it will not
be for long and so what comes down to is
what are the fundamental limitations of
scalability in the cloud era so I think
one of them is you pay attention to
interfaces right so one interface that's
fundamental to computing is the concept
of a computer so the computer under this
guy's desk is just an interface and in
the cloud paradigm it is an interface to
a distributed network of potentially
extremely large numbers of virtual
machines but that the parallel ISM and
scale abilities automatically manage so
the machine is just a metaphor but it
makes it very easy to program it's very
hard to program a million arbitrary
machines it's very easy to program the
one machine under your desk so it goes
from personal computing to universal
computing so from personal experience
this is the number one web site in
Seattle which is called cheezburger
network to universal experience the
scalability of systems constrained by
the amount of fun that people have with
it and finally I just want to talk about
an example and I don't have very much
time but there's a basically a group
startup called smugmug they've created a
cloud system called Skynet and it's
basically a set of autonomic workers
that sit in the Amazon Elastic Compute
cloud so as more tasks come into the
network if 10,000 users suddenly decide
they want to do web-based photo editing
which is what they provide they're going
to autonomic ly generate additional
virtual machines in the compute cloud
very exciting activity it is half a
petabyte of data and it is a profitable
model for business so this is basically
what happened which is you start to see
utilization versus provisioning and as
you can see it's dynamic right so more
and more virtual machines are spawned as
more and more workload is put on to
Skynet so that's basically a model for
that elastic computation so the note
that I kind of wanted to close on is
this build out of this construct of the
software metropolis which is I said
repeatedly that the compute model is not
the
the scalability the limit to scalability
is essentially the integration not of
data the integration not even of
semantics or meaning but the integration
of intentionality which is that
different groups of people people
naturally form Robin Dunbar number size
tribes of 150 people they form these
tribal organizations that naturally
combat one another and they fight for
budget and they fight for head count
this is the nature of large organization
therefore the limits our trustworthiness
common languages the ability to manage
relationships contracts and
accountability complexity so I talked
about some of these design systems
achieving horrifying levels of
complexity that needs to be managed
understanding how do you even
communicate that level of complexity
someone chaos and controllability and
scalability of organization so these are
some of the fundamental limits that we
need to overcome in order to achieve
extreme large-scale systems in the cloud
thank you very much
to to ask some questions help us
speculate on what we just saw try to
make some meaning of all of this and so
I'll just make a quick observation but
very quickly we want to open the floor
to a few questions and we'll probably
try to wrap up in about 15 minutes so
one of the things that I just wanted to
note maybe it goes without saying but
the aesthetic of the of the graphic
presentations in the room tonight was
probably different than anything we've
ever seen at least in a row in this room
and I think that's I think that's
interesting I don't know if that's a
certain message for the aesthetics of
the post parametric but certainly it
suggests a certain kind of conceptual
and maybe even language issue in trying
to think about the way that architects
and and computer scientists we're
talking very broadly now by saying that
everyone here is a computer scientist
but but but that there's some issues of
kind of communicating and finding
graphic language and I certainly think
that the graphics were as compelling as
that the things that we do in
architecture but it's actually not
exactly what we might have dreamed up if
we all collectively as architects
thought about what would the post
parametric future look like with with
that as a kind of observation I think it
wouldn't necessarily make sense to try
to summarize or make some great
conclusion about all of this stuff but
but I did want to bring us back to the
idea of collaboration between fields and
particularly about innovation you know
at a school like this where we're always
thinking about innovation thinking about
new definitions of things thinking about
breakthroughs and so the question I want
to pose to to anyone who presented who
might want to answer is are there
examples or I'll put it this way how do
you design the problems that you set out
to solve
with your with your tools and
technologies like how did how hard do
you come up with the idea of trying to
design a robot that can repair itself or
be self-aware how do we come up with the
idea to to model a building that can
that within the software you can
interact with in real time or you know
even Miko how do you how do you come up
with the problem of the software to
design that you think will be helpful
and as a kind of subtext for that is
there a way for that you can imagine in
your own work for architects as
non-experts almost by definition helping
to to define those problems to create
some kind of feedback loop because it
seems to me like one of the issues might
be that architects as non-experts asking
a lot of stupid questions about these
innovative processes might just seem to
be in the way I'd like to take a crack
even though it's a bit orthogonal which
is one of the things I talked about was
the system of production of software
right so when you look at a very large
company like you know autodesk and in
something like Revit like there's so
many inputs but that ultimately the goal
is to get large purchase orders so
they're not actually designing the
system for use by humans and that
they're cramming features and this is
creating this kind of really horrible
kind of inner interfaces the interfaces
are very very complicated and scary
they're terrifying and so the thing
that's interesting about the innovation
cycle in the cloud is that the cloud
kind of fosters an economic model where
you can actually build software at an
individual level it may not be you
yourself as an architect but it may be a
single programmer building something in
the cloud and that you can actually
start to network these very small and
potentially very intuitive tools you
know it's along the lines of what a tell
is showing so you know I think that a
network of much more simplistic tools
may actually have a multiplying effect
in the cloud and the economic model for
that is I
actually iterative and you know
potentially exponentially growing if it
catches on so that's that's my pitch to
you is is ditch the big monolithic
corporate architecture tools be put on
my my previous career hat as a developer
of software for visual effects studios I
think there's and I I imagine it's very
similar in architecture so I spent a lot
of time working with artists directly
and ya know the languages that people
speak are completely unrelated I mean
it's it's a fascinating thing and
there's this role that in every visual
effects to do there's a fairly small
group of people who can speak speak both
languages who act as these sort of
translators and I think they're the
they're the reason that visual effects
has progressed at all in many ways and
you know where they come from is a is a
good question because I think they tend
to be very diverse so so I'm thinking of
people I've worked with who I know some
people who had art degrees and some
people who had engineering degrees but
in every case they sort of developed the
ability the sensibility in both fields
and the ability to speak fluently in in
both languages and translate between
them and it's a very rare skill but I
would say from the perspective of you
know trying to foster and practice
collaboration between these communities
developing that skill and finding those
people and figuring out how to train
people who can be conversing in both
languages i think is really key again
there's one thing that's driving a lot
of
work that we're doing and that is the
increased complexity of the kind of
things we want to make I think this
pervasive across all of course many
fields that involve design that you just
want to make more complex things that
it's becoming too complicated for a
single person to know and predict what's
going to happen and even four teams of
Engineers let's say to be able to
understand the complexity of the things
that is that we're we want to design and
that's compounded with the fact that the
manufacturing tools now allows the
manufacture of things with such great
complexity that design space cannot be
explored using traditional methods and
so all the things that we've seen today
some things that you've shown a ton are
gonna have to do with with accelerating
the rate of exploration and we're trying
to do is have the machines explore
themselves where to go next actually
kind of take the designer out of the
loop some extent we're going to keep
laughing again we just want to be able
to safety what's the goal and you know
call me text me when you get there but
but it's all about reaching this
historic complexity that cannot be
managed using traditional design
technique so that's what's driving I
just wanted respond really quickly so
first of all how do I was completely
blown away by your presentation i really
love seeing all of what you were doing
and I think that concept of having a
gigantic multi-dimensional search space
that you know that you can crawl or
evolve towards i think is great
methodology but one of the things that I
see in sort of the enterprise domain
very large scale systems is that it
isn't complexity that's some of the
problem that they have some of the
problem that they have is entropy which
is that successful very large scale
systems are kind of necessarily complex
and you have this wonderful kind of like
the biosphere for example tremendously
complex but relatively low entropy right
because it's actually taking solar
energy I'm using it to build a diversity
of form right and so the thing that's
really intriguing to me that
produces entropy within systems is that
people bang against each other and it's
the heterogeneity of intention right I
mean I think that's really the kind of
key puzzle that we've bits that unsolved
and I think in terms of manifesting very
large-scale complex systems commercially
you will have lots of people working for
lots of different entities than all kind
of like want to win and push cost and
complexity and entropy out of that man
into other entities you know which
produced risk will bring up to some
questions from the floor
yeah so the the big pattern that we
looked at in service oriented
architecture is this concept of
externalizing essentially policy and so
this concept that the pattern and you
know I apologize for not translating it
to architectural constructs but you know
essentially what you do is you create
trust by building a framework so I'll
give you an example when people drive on
the roads they don't have an explicit
point-to-point trust relationship with
every other driver on the road right
they have a trust in the framework right
and so what you do is you devise
frameworks and then you create
enforceability and then that way what
happens is the integration of these
different intentionality right so I plan
to do X other person plans to do why we
have some kind of like legislation or
some kind of construct that allows these
things to cooperate so for example you
know it's like sure you can have the air
volume in this building be a certain
size but if it exceeds a certain size
and all of a sudden some environmental
regulation from the government click
Center you know so how do you get these
different very wrong metaphor but the
construct is the same which is how do
you get these different intentionality
xand constraint systems interlock and
you know if you could get them the
interlock in a model that had intuitive
interaction to it would be even better
i'm going to add something there but
redundancy and I think Jonathan can
speak a little bit more to that but
whenever you take the approach of saying
let's go parallel let's try to evaluate
many many different designs at the same
time so whenever you have a parallel
system actually getting the reaping the
benefits of the parallelism is really
hard right and you rarely reap a hundred
percent of the parallelism so if you
have a hundred explorations at the same
time you're not going to get a hundred
times the speed but a very interesting
anecdote for that is is when you have
humans in the loop so with folded the
protein folding project one of the
things that the creators are folded
discovered is that even though there
were you know even though there were so
many ways to fold the protein and that's
ultimately what overwhelmed the computer
even the fastest computer that's trying
to fold a protein is that people even in
the thousands started doing very similar
things all right in part because they
gravitated towards the same things on
their own and in part because all these
bulletin board and forums opened up
where people were sharing strategies
with each other for how to get more
points and fold it because that's what
they're after is getting the points and
being highly ranked for the protein and
so that led to a very interesting
problem which they're working on right
now at the University of Washington
which is how do we create incentive
structures in these programs in these
games like folded to encourage people to
branch out and think outside the box and
try different things right so how can we
reward people from for behaving
differently from other people in this
game and therefore exploring different
designs even if those designs initially
aren't as promising as the tried and
true methods thank you Mark
and computer science is also actually
the word naive right sometimes you hear
this in computer science demonstrations
where people will say for instance well
the naive way of doing this would be and
then they'll say something that seemed
totally reasonable right like of course
that's how something works and that's
the intuitive understanding other right
but then they'll say but clearly this is
a better way to do it right and they'll
say some kind of bizarre optimization
that some genius had to invent right in
computer science seems to be the
accumulation of all these optimizations
which is what makes it really hard to
number one learn also somewhat hard to
teach right but it also just moves it
away from that sense of being intuitive
and I guess my question is once we pass
that real time barrier and once we start
to have this completely elastic cloud
that totally takes off the computed as
you say is there a space then for
naivety it again can we be naive in the
cloud or do we still have to do all the
optimization first because you're a lot
of it I'll just say one thing we
definitely have to rethink what are the
notions of naive and many computer
science programs in the US right now are
rethinking basic education of computer
science with parallelism in mind so what
used to be a task that you know was an N
squared task meaning that if you doubled
the size of the problem it would take
you four times as long if you quadruple
the size of the problem to take you 16
times as long suddenly can become a
linear task in parallel with parallel
ilysm and so some of the notions of what
is obvious and what you should do it
shouldn't do are certainly changing even
at the curriculum level in computer
science I guess I guess I'd like to
respond by saying that that's a kind of
a very computer science the answer
I think you know my crack at this thing
don't lose yeah like I get this thing is
is that the joy of what's happening with
cloud is abstraction right so this
concept of cloud you notice
infrastructure-as-a-service
software-as-a-service right
platform-as-a-service everything is the
service so what is a surface the service
is basically I don't care how it gets
done you do it then you deliver it and
I'm not even looking at you right that's
what a service is right and so what that
means is that kind of abstraction I was
talking about about programming a
computer so I'm programming a computer
that's simpler than programming a
gigantic network of computers right and
so what I'm really trying to say is with
boundless compute capability I think
your hypothesis is true which is that
with a lot of compute power we can
present abstractions that are very very
simple but in fact our underlying
there's a lot of complexity inside of it
and that it's doing the work to make to
give you a very simple interface right
so I think it's possible but I think it
comes back to the means of production of
software which is you know that if you
give people an economic reason to build
hideously complex pieces of software
they'll do that right so that's I think
what the closer to the issue I think
another aspect of that is computer
science is is difficult it's a difficult
engineering field and like all
engineering fields the engineering
trade-offs are the hard part and they're
almost always on intuitive so in defense
of computer science i think is any worse
right like generally what makes
engineering a hard discipline is that
the easy answers tend to not be the best
answers so the advantage of more and
more powerful computers is that you can
actually hide all that complexity the
computer can do the hard work of
figuring out what's the optimal answer
what's you know what's the consequence
if you put in these parameters what do
you get at the other end or it can let
you be intentional and say here's what
here's what I'm intending you tell me
where in the dot design space will give
me that answer
I don't know where it is or you know
what a time and I was showing that the
idea that you can have a really
difficult to the the path from input
parameters to output result can be you
know really really complicated sequence
of computations but you know if that's
interactive then you're sort of directly
it almost feels like you're directly
driving the output right instead of this
sort of process or input wait an hour to
get output and so I think as computers
actually get faster and faster the
intuition of of these complex systems
actually increases because you can
actually develop the intuition directly
by playing with the system itself so I
think it's actually hopeful as as
computers get faster and more
complicated for the naive users to
actually use complicated systems to do
interesting things let's take one more
question and then left to wrap up way in
the back back row highest hand
okay a great great lecture by the whole
panel so back here we've been kind of
wondering there's like a kind of
underlying theme of utopia and dystopia
in a way right like there's an image of
Skynet right a company actually makes a
company called Skynet and with like a
real kind of quote about possible
futures and I guess we're all wondering
that it seems like there's an end goal
to some to some of the and in different
fields it seems to be like an end goal
liking at least in graphics right the
angle would be reality to some to some
degree right that we're going to
completely be able to simulate reality
in robotics it might be the autonomy of
a robot right it might be Autonomy's the
end goal and I wonder I guess we're
wondering here like is is that something
that's conscious conscious to the minds
of people within those fields like the
kind of consequences of that and I don't
know I mean it's not the worst escape I
mean there's a kind of like promised to
everything but at the same time there's
a kind of like we've seen so many
scenarios that play out in very bad ways
and I'm not and I'm not like a I'm not a
conspiracy theorist I mean you know I'm
extremely hopeful about it but at the
same time like I'll show my dad a video
of a TED talk and he'll be like where's
this were like you know he's whatever
he's not up to date with technology with
they'll just be like where is it going
you know where does it end in a way so i
was wondering like what are the goals I
guess what are the angles is it even
seen it in the profession or in the
fields so uh but the question seems to
be is tomorrow gonna be wonderful with
all our needs fulfilled and wonderful
robotic doctors where is it going to be
the day-to-day fight for life against
humanoid robot killer
I can try to I can try to speak for
robot as a designer hunter-killer but so
so the I think the direction is Alana me
but the end goal is not clear because
you don't know what how much autonomy
what kind of intelligence all these
things so it's not clear where it's
going it's probably but we want to get
more autonomy and I think that it's a I
used to think you know you don't need to
worry about it go worried about
genetically modified crops or something
else but none of our robotics because
you can unplug them but the truth is it
is a powerful technology and I think the
only way to deal with it is to have
public discussions just like we have in
here you know here's what we're doing it
looks cool there's probably more
benefits than harm and the potential but
let's just keep it open and see where it
goes because nobody knows where it's
going let me just follow up with a quick
comment which is you know what it
suggests in your comment suggests is is
that we're actually still not
necessarily in post parametric but we
may actually be in postmodern right
which is that you know one of the things
we need to really study is who whose
intention is served right because
ultimately these entities in their
behaviors project an intentionality so
if you're looking at a design space you
could look at a design space of what's
the most efficient way to create a green
building that's an interesting design
space what's the most cost-effective way
to kill 50 million people right that's a
different design space horrible dystopia
design space right but the thing that I
think ultimately have to consider is
whose intentions are being extended and
how do these systems serve those
intentions and I think your question is
extremely thoughtful because you know
everyone needs to examine those
questions yeah I to really really
appreciate the question because it
indicate
the kind of moving from the means to the
ends and i think that the notion of post
parametric in a way is like a relief to
me because we might actually get back to
the business of creating kind of sublime
human human experience of space or the
kind of things that have constituted you
know the architectural education and
design practice for so long that seems
to have gotten really pushed down under
encountering tools so i'm looking
forward to getting back to business in a
way and i think that's that's a good way
to wrap up this is obviously just the
beginning of the discussion but i want
to thank all of our speakers i want to
thank our sponsors Columbia Department
of Computer Science blue sky studios and
Bentley Systems Incorporated and I want
to thank everyone in the audience for
being willing to bend your mind in
multiple directions at once so hopefully
this is to be continued thank